ཡོང་གླེང་སློབ་གྲྭར་འགྲོ་༼གི་༽ཡོད་རེད།
ང་ཚོ་༼ར་༽ཀ་ཁ་དེ་ཚོ་སྦྱང་གི་ཡོད་རེད།
ཚལ་རིགས་སྐྱོར་གི་ཡོད་རེད།
ཡར་ལངས་ནས་སྐྱོར་གི་ཡོད་རེད།
དུ་ལུམ་མ་དེ་ཚོ་ཤེས་༼གི་༽ཡོད་རེད། སོ་ལོ་
གོང་ལ་ཕུག མེ་ཏོག་པད་ཚལ།
ཚལ། ལྒ་སྨུག སྒོག་པ། ཨ་ཤོམ། མཛུབ་ཚལ། ཊོ་མེ་ཊོ།
ཤ་མོང་། ཙོང་།
ཙོང་ལྗང་། ཞོ་ཁོག ལ་ཕུག ལིམ་བུ།
ཡོང་མ།
རྫོགས་ཚར་རེད།
རྒན་བདེ་སྐྱིད་ལགས།
ཀ་ བ་ ཀ་བ་བསླབ་༼གི་༽ཡོད་རེད་ང་ཚོ་ལ།
མ་རེད།
ཅོ་ཅོ་སྒང་ལ་བསྡད་༼གི་༽ཡོད་རེད། ང་འོག་བསྡད་༼གི་༽ཡོད་རེད།
ཞོགས་པ་ཆུ་བཏུང་བྱེད་༼གི་༽ཡོད་རེད།
སོ་བཀྲུ་གི་ཡོད་རེད།
གདོང་པ་བཀྲུ་གི་ཡོད་རེད།
ཁ་ལག་ཟ་གི་ཡོད་རེད།
པ་ལགས་ལ་ལག་པ་འཐམ་ནས་འགྲོ་༼གི་༽ཡོད་རེད།
ཞལ་འདོན་སྐྱོར་ག་འགྲོ་༼གི་༽ཡོད་རེད།
ཅོ་ཅོ་དང་ང་ཚོ།
འདི་བལྟ་གི་ཡིན།
རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་ས་འདུག
འདི་ Circle
འདི་ག་རེ་རེད།
དང་ཤོས་དེ་ག་རེ་རེད།
ཁྱི། ཁྱི་འགྲོ་༼གི་༽འདུག་ཁོ་མཉམ་དུ་འགྲོ་༼གི་༽འདུག
མི་དེ་འདི་ལ་ལག་པ་གཅིག་ཟིམ་འདུག ཤིང་དེ་ཟིམ་འདུག
ཤིང་གིས་འབྲི་༼གི་༽འདུག་ཁོང་ཚོ།
ཤིང་དེ་མར་འབྲུ་འགྲོ་༼གི་༽ཡོད་རེད།
འདི་ངང་པ་རེད་དེ་
འདི་ངང་པ་རེད། ངང་པ་ཆུ་ནང་ལ་འགྲོ་༼གི་༽ཡོད་རེད།
ངང་པ་གཉིས། ངང་པ་ང་ཚོའི་ནང་ལ་ཡོད་རེད།
ངང་པ་ཡོད་མ་རེད། ཉ་ཡོད་རེད། ཉ་གཅིག་གཉིས་གསུམ། གསུམ་ཡོད་རེད།
ཉ་དེ་ཚོ་དགེ་ལེགས་མཉམ་དུ་ཡོང་གི་འདུག
རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་བསྡད་༼ཞག༽ ཁོང་ཚོ་གཉིས།
ས་ཆ་ཆུང་ཆུང་མི་འདུག ཆེན་པོ་འདུག
ཤིང་ཏོག གཞན་པ་
འདི་ག་རེ་རེད།
གཟུགས་པོ་ཁྲུས་ས་ཆུང་ཆུང་
baby ༼ཁ་གྱི་༽གཟུགས་པོ་བཀྲུ་ས་རེད། གཞན་པ་གཅིག་བལྟ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན།
ག་རེ་བྱེད་འདུག་ཁོང་ཚོ།
བྱེད་༼གི་༽མི་འདུག་ག
མ་བྱེད། མ་བྱེད། མ་བྱེད་ད་ཨ་ཅག ང་གཅིག་བལྟ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན།
ག་རེ་བྱེད་འདུག་བལྟ་དགོས།
ངས་གཅིག་བལྟ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན། ངས་ད་ལྟ་གཅིག་འདུག་བསམ་སོང་།
ང་རང་ང་རང་ འདི་སྦུག་ལ་གཅིག་ཡོད།
སྐར་མ་གཅིག་སྒུགས་ཨ། འདི་སྦུག་ལ་ག་རེ་ཡོད་རེད་བལྟ་དགོས།
ག་རེ་ཡོད་རེད། འདི་སྦུག་ལ་
ཡི་གེ་
གཅིག་བལྟ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན། ང་རང་ང་རང་བལྟ་འདོད་ཡོད། གཅིག་བལྟ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན།
ག་རེ་འདུག་ལབ་དགོས་བས།
ཅི་གང་ལ་དགའ་པོ་མེད།
ང་ལོ་གསུམ་ཚར་རེད། ལོ་བཞི་ཚར་༼འགྲོའོ་༽ཡོད་རེད། ང་Happy Birdday བཏང་ཚར་བདེ་ལེགས་ངེད་གཉིས།
ངས་གསར་པ་གཅིག་སྟོན་ཡིན།
ལགས། ཡི་གེ་བྲིས་མེད།
ཡར་སྒང་ལ་འབུ།  འབུ་ཆུང་ཆུང་
འབུ་ཆུང་ཆུང་དེས་འདི་ཟ་ཡི་འདུག
འབུ་ཡིན་གྱི་རེད།
ད་དེ་ཕལ་ཕྱོགས་ཟུར་དེ།
འདི་ལ་ག་རེ་ཡོད་རེད།